Пів мільйона доз Covishield відвантажують для відправки в Україну.
Цю індійську вакцину від COVID-19 розподілять між областями, аби робити щеплення українцям згідно з планом вакцинації Мінохоронздоров’я.
Що це за вакцина? Наскільки вона ефективна? І чи безпечна?
Що таке Covishield?
Covishield - це похідна вакцина від спільної розробки Оксфордського університету та фармацевтичної компанії AstraZeneca.
За великим рахунком це та сама вакцина, але вироблена в Індії за ліцензією.
Ще влітку минулого року AstraZeneca підписала з найбільшим у світі виробником вакцин - Інститутом сироватки Індії -
відповідну угоду про виготовлення мільярда доз вакцин для країн з низьким та середнім рівнем доходу.
Як діє Covishield?
В основі вакцини - аденовірус шимпанзе зі зниженою здатністю до реплікації.
Коли вакцина вводиться пацієнтові, це спонукає імунну систему виробляти антитіла та захищати від будь-якої коронавірусної інфекції.
Подібно до AstraZeneca і BioNTech/Pfizer вакцинація препаратом Covishield теж передбачає щеплення
двома дозами з перервою від чотирьох до 12 тижнів між ними.
Одна з переваг цієї вакцини - це зберігання за температури від двох до восьми градусів, тобто як у звичайному холодильнику.
Це також полегшує транспортування між регіонами.
Адже, приміром, вакцину від BioNTech/Pfizer потрібно зберігати і перевозити за температури близько -70 за Цельсієм.
Чи безпечна Covishield?
З одного боку, Covishield - це аналог вакцини від Oxford-AstraZeneса,
яка отримала реєстрацію від Європейського агентства з лікарських засобів.
З іншого боку, Covishield як продукт Інституту сироватки Індії має дозвіл на використання в умовах надзвичайної ситуації,
тобто це дозвіл на використання незареєстрованої вакцини.
Це не означає, що вакцина неякісна чи небезпечна.
Просто ще немає повної інформації про результати досліджень.
Приміром, чи є обмеження щодо застосування для певних вікових груп.
Так, у деяких європейських країнах, зокрема у Німеччині, людям, яким понад 65 років, не роблять щеплення вакциною AstraZeneca.
Якщо ж Covishield - це її ліцензійний аналог, то не виключено, що індійський препарат теж не варто колоти літнім людям,
адже даних клінічних випробувань щодо цих вікових груп бракує.
Водночас, згідно з українським планом вакцинації, перші щеплення мають отримати саме літні люди та медики.
Думки українських експертів щодо Covishield розділилися.
Одні запевняють, що це якісна вакцина, виготовлена в умовах і на обладнанні, які сертифіковані спеціалістами ВООЗ.
А сам виробник - Інститут сироватки Індії - відомий своїми якісними вакцинами від інших хвороб.
Інші ж експерти вказують на відносно низьку ефективність Covishield  - лише 63 відсотки.
При цьому також повідомляється, що для більшого ефекту варто робити довший інтервал між першою і другою дозами вакцини.
Не два-три тижні, а більше. Тоді ефективність вакцини нібито може досягати і 90 відсотків.
Окрім України, одними з перших вакцину Covishield отримали такі азійські країни як Бутан, Бангладеш, Непал, М'янма.